we do thank you for joining us at 11 I'm
Brian Loftus another day today basking
in the Sun as Valley residents welcome
these warmer temperatures but when it
comes to managing the heat how do people
cope and what do you need to do to
protect yourself against heat exhaustion
or heat stroke Madison Kimbrough joins
us now live in studio with what people
and doctors are saying yeah Brian I can
almost guarantee you that most of our
viewers right now are sitting
comfortably in an air-conditioned room
and earlier today we spoke to those who
officially turned theirs on while
sharing how they manage the heat while
Outdoors too
this week was the first time we turned
it on they had to the house got up to 80
something last night I was like all
right we gotta gotta flip the switch
just how it goes Cameron Johnson talking
about his air conditioning unit while
enjoying an afternoon with his son and
dog Johnson soaking up the Sun but knows
it's only the beginning air conditioning
fans are in all the rooms I mean I feel
like if you had any events anytime you
know that that's going to be the
standard and for others managing the
heat means having a plan like Kelly
biederman who was an avid Park goer with
her three dogs when it starts to get 90
to 100 to over we'll be going out at
like five in the morning or after dark
going out when the sun isn't directly
overhead or staying somewhere with trees
and shade for these guys especially over
at concierge Wellness Center in the
southwest Valley Dr Christopher Choi
sharing with 8 news now what he has seen
amid these Rising temperatures I
actually met a young lady in the
emergency room
uh because she was it was July and she
was running outside
when it was very very hot
and she wasn't drinking enough fluids
and she got hit exhaustion water and
electrolytes are key for when you're out
in the heat but also make sure you're
dressed properly too and while everyone
needs to stay hydrated there are
particular age groups that need to be
extra cautious too so little kids and
the elderly folks they're much much more
prone to getting dehydrated they need to
drink a lot of fluids with electrolytes
yeah I'm talking about two to three
liters a day
yeah Dr Troy also mentioning how heat
exhaustion and heat stroke are two very
different things with heat exhaustion
people often get dizzy and nauseous
while with a heat stroke someone might
seem confused or suffer from a seizure
that's when it's time to call 9-1-1